there are five sublimely gifted women
nominated for Best Actress in a leading
role the nominees are Amy Adams American
hustle Cate Blanchett blue Jasmine
Sandra Bullock gravity Judi Dench
Philomena Meryl Streep August Osage
County and the Oscar goes to Cate
Blanchett
sit down you're too old to be standing
Thank You mr. day-lewis from you it
exacerbates this honor - and it blows it
right out of the ballpark thank you so
much to the Academy as as random and as
subjective as this award is it means a
great deal in a year of extraordinary
yet again extraordinary performances by
women Amy Adams everything you do but
their performance in American hustle
blew my mind and Meryl what can I say
Sandra I could watch that performance to
the end of time and I sort of felt like
I had Julia hashtag suck it you know
what I mean
and judi dench I mean what a career
she's not here tonight because at the
age of 79 her film was so successful
that she's in India doing a sequel I
mean what a career that is if I could
hope and me I'm here accepting award in
an extraordinary screenplay by Woody
Allen thank you so much woody for
casting me I truly appreciate it I'm so
very proud that blue Jasmine stayed in
the cinemas for as long as it did and
thank you to Sony classics to Michael
and Tom for their extraordinary support
for so bravely and intelligently
distributing the film and to the
audience's who went to see it and
perhaps those of us in the industry who
are still foolishly clinging to the idea
that that female films with women at the
center unleash experiences they are not
audiences want to see them and in fact
they earn money so
people thank you to my mum to my sister
to my brother to my three glorious sons
I would not be standing here without you
- my husband Andrew you are a legend
- thank thank you to my agent Hilda
Creely you're behind the pillars
somewhere up there you are a goddess -
my agent in Australia
Robin Gardner I love you so very much -
my em publicist Lisa castella to the
sublime Sally Hawkins and to the
extraordinary cast of blue Jasmine I
don't know how to do this without other
actors and this I share with you - the
hair and makeup people who sweated me up
and tried to make me look attractive
thank you for the attempt to Carla Maia
for getting Sally and I together and
food incredible support - Helen Robin -
to everyone involved in in blue Jasmine
I thank you so much and finally I would
like to thank every single member of the
Sydney Theatre Company one of the great
theatre companies in the world for me
working on blue Jasmine it was a real
synthesis of my work in the theatre and
on film and not only working with you
for the last six years has been a most
enormous privilege of my career but it's
maybe a better actress there is so much
talent in Australia and Michael
Wilkinson and cm and I are just the
tonight's tip of the iceberg thank you
so much thank you